[Music]
we don't build
five mile high skyscrapers because our s
we can't we don't have steel
strong enough to put into the base of
them but if a
skyscraper were to be made of light were
to be made in virtual reality
it can be a hundred miles high there are
no constraints
in the imagination the only constraints
are of the imagination a very
interesting
um exercise to undertake some time
and we did this at la cherera a lot
because we thought that it was not an
exercise but that we were going to be
called upon to do it
is ask yourself how would i live
if i could live any way i wanted
and then in your mind begin to construct
your environment you start off sloppy
you say well i'll start with versailles
and then i'll remodel from there
give me versailles and let me walk
around and see what i want and if i'm
going to
bring the sphinx or what exactly how to
arrange
but very quickly you know that becomes
very boring
and you say well you know could i send
drops of water 50 feet across in the air
above my lawn just for the light show of
it
well of course you could or anything
else and once you begin
imagining away from the constraints of
money and matter and time you just say
my god
the human imagination unleashed is an
engine for the creation of archetectonic
beauty on scales we can barely conceive
of
this will all happen in our lifetime we
aren't going to build
ring worlds and visit other star systems
except in virtual reality but it will be
as
real as it can be and the japanese god
love them
have already pushed the technology to
the place where they've been able to
eliminate the suit
they install lasers in the walls that
track your body movement without you
even knowing it
they've gotten rid of the suit now all
you need is the glasses
and within you know 10 or 15 years
people will
be doing this living in the imagination
to my mind then if we could if we could
micro miniaturize the
infrastructure that is supporting this
technology
and put it all inside mount everest or
something and get it out of sight
then we would be very close to the
reconstruction
of eden i mean my idea of where this is
all supposed to come and what the final
scene
before the big fade out is is
a world in dynamic ecological balance
its oceans pure its atmosphere pure
and in that world human beings
living a tribal lifestyle
naked healthy imbalanced
but if you're one of these people and
you close your eyes
there are menus hanging in space
and these menus let you into your
culture
which has become completely invisible
you can't
see it unless you have the entry codes
and so then you you have an apartment on
the 985th
floor of the the ansoniatan hotel
in hyperspace or whatever it is but
whenever you want
you can simply open your eyes and you're
sitting
on this flawless beach with this
flawless ocean
in other words we have to interiorize
our culture
[Music]
you